the Joe Rogan experience how did you get
linked up with Sean but Sean is such a
polarizing figure because yes he's the
carnivore go-to guy and he's like a
full-on carnivore zealot as it were yeah
I mean he doesn't even he thinks
vegetables are bad for me so I think
Sean sometimes gets misrepresented and
part of it is just like you know way he
interacts on social media and stuff but
he's uh you I met Sean like before he I
think went full carnivore but on Twitter
and we I thought he was an interesting
person not because of what he ate so
what's he doing back then was he was he
was kind of more like high fat low carb
I think something pretty similar to what
I'm doing
maybe maybe less carbohydrates since his
activity levels are like really short
and fast and you know I just thought he
was an interesting person because of his
background I mean he's you know a
Highlands game athlete professional
rugby player he's doing this
high-intensity gigantic yeah yeah I mean
he's twice my size like it so it's like
my thought is like okay here's a guy
who's has a similar nutrition plan that
I do but he's doing the exact opposite
athlete type stuff he's twice the size
of me like it's what kind of tunes that
expect ends of the spectrum from like an
athletic standpoint so like I was just
interested in kind of like you know what
he was doing and what he was up to and
that's kind of why we started the
podcast together and but yeah I mean
when you one of the things that Sean
always says on the podcast I think is is
a kind of a better reflection room he'll
say I don't the only thing I know for
certain is that I'm wrong about
something so it's like you know it it
gets I think it gets tough for someone
like him who gets identified as the like
the face of the carnivore movement
because then like you get all the
positive and a negative coming your way
too and I mean you can feed into that
but I mean when we when we record our
podcasts and stuff is he I mean he's a
very open-minded person we're looking
for answers and we're asking questions
and things like that and it's it's it's
you know it's a learning experience I
think for me anyway so well he clearly
enjoys [ __ ] with vegans well yeah and
it's he's been on this fruitarian kick
lately which is kind of hilarious
I didn't know there was that many those
people
out there yeah one of them just died
when one fruitarian doctor died during a
fast really yeah and Sean was talking
about it on his youtube channel yeah
there's people out there that think that
you could just get by by only eating
fruit mm-hmm Jesus Christ folks you know
I've got a theory with like social media
and that stuff in general is that like
for a lot of a lot of the people who are
most active on it it's like they're they
either take it 100% serious or it's like
kind of a joke or a game and then when
those two polar ends meet it's that's
where you get the big kind of like you
like blow up interactions and then yeah
and then it becomes a like kind of a
game of like well the vegan told me that
like I should die or something like that
so now I'm gonna go tell that vegan that
you know this that and it goes back and
forth back and forth back so stupid this
is such a waste of time but the most
interest the one I always get a kick out
of though along those lines is someone
will come up with like a picture of like
here's here's the humans you know jaw
system and this clearly means we're
frugivores and then someone will say
well look at the the digestive tract of
a human being is clearly designed more
to be eating meat or animal products and
you know they go back and forth with
different like parts of the human
anatomy to try to like prove that were
vegetarian or vegan fruitarian organs
are so stupid and then I'm thinking the
whole time I'm like so what we have here
is people who can have to have specific
traits that are good for eating fruits
and vegetables and some specific traits
that are good for eating animal products
so we're omnivores biologically it's
been established not there's no real
controversy the controversies fake look
particularly from the vegans where they
say they were herbivores and our jaws
are designed to crush you know right
roots and [ __ ] like no no no we had
tools and fire yeah for [ __ ] hundreds
of thousands of years you knuckleheads
you know who one of them my favorite
podcast we've done was with this guy dr.
bill Schindler he's an archaeologist I
would hope I think his Washington
University and he's such a cool dude he
like totally what he said something I
was really resonated with me where he
said you know humans were unique in that
like we we've we've like over time
developed ways to use like tools and
things like that to liberate nutrients
so to look at anything in this raw state
is kind of the missed the point of why
humans are the way they are sure we'll
like lentils mm-hmm like I've seen this
argument that human beings aren't
supposed to eat meat because if we were
we would be able to just wrap it apart
and eat it with our own teeth and go go
eat a squirrel with your face well guess
what you can't eat a squirrel with your
face if you're so inclined if you really
wanted to do that you could do it
without tools uh-huh you know you can't
do you can't eat a lot of beans if I'm
cooking them like we have we've figured
things out folks
I mean cassava in the jungle they
figured out that you have to cook this
stuff and strain it and it's a primary
staple of the diets of many people that
live in the in the jungle you know and
it's [ __ ] toxic as [ __ ] if you don't
do that I mean it literally produces
cyanide cyanide is produced by cassava
which is like one of their primary foods
they just figured it out
just like you figured out you have to
boil lentils just like you figured out
you have to cook beans uh-huh I mean you
can't eat most of these things that we
eat are not good to eat if you just eat
them in their raw state some things like
fruits are some vegetables are but some
just are not and this is the same with
meat and it's this idea that you're
supposed to be where we're clearly an
herbivore because of the fact that we
you know we're not supposed to be you
know killing animals with our teeth like
that's so dumb like we we kill animals
with tools and we've done it for so long
that our bodies have adapted we've
adapted to the fact that we have clothes
that's why we're not covered in hair you
[ __ ] idiot like this is not this is
like real clear obvious stuff people who
live in the coldest climates of the
world aren't covered in hair you know
yeah you know and it was interesting
because like what you're saying to when
when we had Bill on the show he he's got
this unique experience what he's
actually gone in and visited these
indigenous tribes have been relatively
untouched by modern society to basically
with the one question level how do you
eat so he's been he's seen like a
variety of different stuff I think even
had a show on National Geographic for a
while that looked into some of this but
he like just to show you the
polarization of what humans can kind of
do he he went he visited the Sun burrow
which is a branch of
maasai over in africa you know they're
they're basically drinking blood and
milk for the for a huge portion of their
nutrition and you know so you have this
this this tribe that's basically on a
primarily animal-based nutrition plan
and they're super healthy he said that
there maybe one of the most healthy
groups of people he's seen from just
like a physical stature like toothed
health and that sort of thing but then
he also went down to I think was in
South America camera the name of the
tribe but they found a way to basically
liberate nutrients from a poisonous
potato and Sabah is that what it was me
that's what we're talking about okay
yeah um yeah so I think it was maybe was
cassava or maybe there's other ones yeah
I think there is a purple some weird
purple potato that has a similar sort of
a toxic profile yeah and what he said
was this this tribe they're a basically
mostly potatoes what they would do is
they'd literally dig like a pit and put
like some like like thousands of pounds
of these potatoes in there and let them
sit there and like ferment I guess for
like up to six months oh and then they
would actually make this a clay that
they would use and because there was
still a toxin or something in there that
they needed to kind of prevent from like
interacting totally different yeah so
they would they take that as clay and as
potato and when they dip the potato in
this clay its it like binds to that
toxin so it becomes it doesn't become an
issue when you eat it
so like by itself that potato could
potentially kill you I guess but with
the clay it doesn't and so I was like
how the [ __ ] did they figure that that's
what I want to know I'm thinking like
how much trial and error goes into that
like oh this guy dropped dead this guy
dropped well this guy lived I guess
there's so many things like that in the
jungle you just have to really wonder
how do they develop all these different
medicines and all these different ways
of eating thing it's just fascinating
when like your I guess when your only
goal when you wake up in the morning is
to find your next meal yeah and you know
kind of build build enough around so
that you can kind of survive like you
put a lot of time and energy into it but
yeah it is interesting to think like how
they all got passed along from
generation to generation and how it got
fine-tuned to where it is today
but I think it's it's cool to look at
that stuff when it just comes to your
own nutrition too and kind of when you
understand like it's less about like
this food is net bad for me or this this
food is this particular
food item is bad for me across the board
and this one is great for me across the
board more so about well this is what
this food does well this is what this
one does well
so let's find like you mentioned mix and
match to where you get get the profile
that you're looking for yeah I think the
problem is what we're saying before is
that people are entering into these
conversations with this this goal that
they want to achieve this goal being
plants are bad for you or meat is bad
for you or we're supposed to be only
eating meat or we're supposed to be only
eating plants and here's why and you
know you have this confirmation bias
you're not looking at any other piece of
evidence and particularly the biological
variability of human beings is pretty
incredible yeah I mean I can eat peanuts
all day long if you're allergic to
peanuts you're dead if you eat one it's
it's uh we're we're strange creatures
and what does this change what do you
got here Jamie the ancient oh here it is
the ancient and ancient Andean
tradition of eating clay may have helped
to protect health I think it goes back
to ancient Egypt I was just trying to oh
wow how far back this goes and probably
you could still buy clay dust right now
it's my kind of looking that up too so
eating dirts good for you yeah for this
I found a way to like package the dust
and right Peruvian clay dust this is a
whole history on potatoes here it is the
world and like while potatoes are laced
with solanine and Toma teen toxic
compounds believed to defend plants
against attacks from dangerous organisms
like fungi bacteria and human beings we
are dangerous organisms cooking often
breaks down such chemical defenses but
solanine and toma teen are unaffected by
heat in the mountains
Wow say that word Guang Guang echo in
the Cunha like llamas wild relatives of
the llama lick clay before eating
poisonous plants the [ __ ] llamas
figured it out the toxins stick more
technically absorbed to the fine clay
particles in the animal stomachs passing
through the digestive system without
affecting it mimicking this process
mountain peoples apparently learn to
dunk wild potatoes in a gravy made of
clay and water eventually they bread
toxic potatoes though some of the old
poisonous varieties remain flavored for
their resistance to furrow favored for
their resistance to frost clay dust is
still sold in Peruvian and Bolivian
markets to accompany them Wow
interesting it's crazy but it tastes
like [ __ ] though
still dirt street and dirt with potatoes
[Applause]